that's what julia fox has coined as
their new couple names on monday the
actress posted this photo of her and
kanye west during paris fashion week to
her instagram story captioning it quote
juliet with a black heart emoji i'm
winning every situation and if juliet
rings a bell that's probably because
it's so similar to kim kardashian and
kanye's nickname as a couple kimye you
just gotta roll with it well when it
comes to kanye and julia's budding
relationship on sunday they made their
red carpet debut as a couple
rocking aw denim as they attended the
kinzo fashion show as part of paris
fashion week
the pair also donned this all black
leather ensemble with kanye wearing a
full black ski mask
and julia accessorizing her look with
gold statement earrings a gold purse and
a black bold smokey eye the uncut gems
actress even shared this photo to her
instagram story which seemingly shows
kanye touching up her makeup for this
leather dress and metallic boots look
she captioned it quote want to know who
my favorite makeup artist is it's funny
because i'm getting all this attention
but i'm like i really couldn't care like
people are like oh you're only in it for
the fame you're in it for the clout
you're in it for the money and it's like
honey like i dated billionaires my
entire adult life okay let's keep it
real on friday julia debunked rumors
that she's dating kaye west for fame
clout or money on her podcast forbidden
fruits adding that dating billionaires
is nothing new for her
people are like oh you're only in it for
the fame you're in it for the clout
you're in it for the money and it's like
honey like i dated billionaires my
entire adult life okay let's keep it
real julia and kanye have been turning
heads with their pda filled romance
since the start of 2022 since meeting
the pair have had date nights in new
york city in los angeles including
outings with madonna and even posed for
a pda filled spread for interview
magazine
though previous sources told et that
kanye was trying to repair his marriage
to kim kardashian who filed for divorce
in february of 2021 another source
shares that the father of four is now
trying to move on from kim who is
enjoying a whirlwind romance of her own
with pete davidson saying quote kanye
has been in good spirits lately and
having fun he's been spending time with
friends going out and doing his thing
he's dating around and figuring out what
he likes in a potential partner
[Music]
you